[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you hello everybody over the last
10 years I've had the chance to be part
of an incredible team that has always
pushed the limits of Assassin's Creed
and shown us different periods of our
past but our imagination has always been
bound to the reality of the history
books these past four years our minds
have lingered on a different aspect of
our history mythology the stories of the
ancient gods and their misadventures
have existed through generations of
storytellers and audiences and I've
transformed into tales that we still
know and love today
now these stories have shaped our dreams
inspiring us to build something new
something that transcends the limits
that we have always set upon ourselves
today I am very proud to have the chance
to show you a glimpse to show you a
teaser of this brand-new game that we've
been working on I hope you enjoy it
thank you and have a great a three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when heroes need help they turn to the
gods
[Music]
and gods need help
and they turn to you
[Music]
[Music]
here we are hello everybody
let me begin